[Music]
based on the terrible books from one of
the shittiest authors of all time comes
a movie adaptation for teenage girls who
aren't smart enough for the Hunger Games
you'll be on the edge of your seat as
voiceover describes everything I would
miss my hair bring mother I used to
spend two weeks almost every summer we
first day at a new school kind of like a
book
actually this catatonic teenager will
fall for the world's gayest vampire a
film that teaches young girls that the
only thing that matters is finding a man
a hundred-year-old man but don't worry
it's not pedophilia because he looks 17
together they will have the romance of a
lifetime expressed entirely in stares
[Music]
and even more stairs
a love challenged by the fact that he
might accidentally fur to death this
special effect and her inability to pour
ketchup a film indigenous to think that
love is keeping tabs on each other every
waking moment did you follow me and feel
protective and even non waking moments
just a past couple of months uh I know
this looks creepy but it's but it's
really romantic in the movie I promise
starring Anila shovel face and Troy
Polamalu
Twilight it's just a metaphor for
abstinence seriously look it up get
ready for an hour and a half of people
standing in semi circles council
meetings different council meetings and
city just to get to five minutes of cool
[Music]